hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar remote autonomous molecular
analytical laboratories
at sea and on land i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by microgem
to learn more about microgems visit them
at
microgem microgymbio.com so let's get
started
before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentations
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just simply click on the support tab
found at the top
right corner of your presentation window
or report the problem by clicking on the
ask a question
located at the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker christina
preston a research specialist at the
monterey bay aquarium research
institute for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen christina you
may now begin
your presentation welcome
well thank you very much for that kind
introduction and i hope that you enjoy
my talk today
well today i'm going to talk about the
instruments that are featured within
these videos
and these instruments are our underwater
laboratories
the one on the right shows our mobile
platform known as a long-range
underwater autonomous vehicle
carries our sampling robot and you just
saw it being deployed and now you're
seeing
the water column from the vehicle's
perspective at as it flies through the
water column and eventually
it will encounter a jam of jellies the
video on the left
shows a person diving on a moored
instrument
and both of these instruments are able
to provide data while in their
environment and are the focus of today's
talk
and before i really get started i wanted
to at least talk a little bit
about our group i work at the monterey
bay aquarium research institute
and i work in a group that develops
sensors in order to
help facilitate underwater research and
we're a really diverse group
we span scientists that are
microbiologists
and molecular biologists as well as
engineers
of mechanical electrical and software
so a really diverse group and our main
goal is to basically be able to provide
new means to study in aquatic
environments
and so i want to start introducing you
to
why someone would want to utilize
robotic samplers and then talk about
really the challenges of moving the lab
meaning a molecular lab
directly into the aquatic environment
and i'm going to utilize ambari solution
which is known as the environmental
sample processor
and you might hear me refer to it as the
esp
and the idea of the esp originated with
chrysoline over
25 years ago and chris really wanted to
move the lab into the ocean for the
real-time detection of harmful algal
blooms in our
in our oceans and although the esp was
originally designed for that one
particular task
it's really expanded to a wide range of
organisms and analytes
and you might hear me also utilize the
ver terms
second generation and third generation
or sec or 2g
esp or 3g esp and that just refers to
the version of that particular
instrument
in today's talk i'm really going to
focus on reagent selection and testing
that was performed to support the
molecular assays for nucleic acid
and toxin detection and quantification
the other capability of the instrument
sample preservation has also been
important for our various collaborators
as many of the methods that they use
aren't quite amenable to automation
by the esp
this next video shows one of our ships
leaving port and heading out on a
research cruise and ambari is located
just at the top of this particular at
the top of that video
and this is just to remind everybody
that ocean sciences is quite
expeditionary it means moving your lab
into
onto a ship and heading out to sea in
order to collect the samples
and one issue of having to rely on ships
is means that you're also
tied to its schedule and one that's
often uh determined a year in advance
and those schedules really have impacts
as to when we can get into the field to
study particular phenomena
we really we know in general the time of
the year each particular phenomenon
occurs for example
in monterey bay harmful algal blooms
occur in the spring phytoplankton and
fall
phytoplankton blooms and so we know in
general when they occur
but if you had to pick a week maybe that
bloom didn't quite
get initiated then so being able to
leave behind an instrument
um that can span that time frame of a
particular phenomenon
that you want to study is a really great
asset
it could monitor for and once that
phenomena arrives
you could increase its sampling rate and
capture samples during that particular
time
often whenever we go to sea we are
trying to collect samples and for many
of us
us that means bringing water back to the
ship this is one of those instruments
this is a ctd rosette
with a a bunch of water sampling niskans
and when these niskans go down they're
open like this example here and they're
open on both ends
so when you reach a depth of water that
you want to sample
those niskan bottles close capturing
that water and that's what you're seeing
here that those niskans have all been
sampled
and then you bring that niskan bottle up
to the surface of the
ship you have to drain the water then
you take it into the lab where
that water gets filtered so already you
could imagine
that you've collected the water there's
a delay between when it gets
onto the ship to where you even get to
drain the bottles in process and there's
also an environmental change
and so being able to process water in
its environment is a really key feature
and a lot of people have started to
develop robotic samplers that will
actually do just that
they provide a way to either maintain a
longer presence
they also decouple sampling from ship
operations during a particular research
cruise
and they also provide a means to
preserve water immediately and
under its environmental conditions some
of these instruments also
can perform experiments they can either
add tracers and then track that over
time
or they can actually even provide
molecular information
and if you're interested in these types
of of instruments there's two really
good reviews one by addison and one by
mcquellan and robidar
that are available
one thing that everybody's going after
really are organisms that are
um captured within this droplet of water
and so
really the ocean is a genetic soup of
its resident species and this is a great
quote from kelly at all from 2014 and
that means
within this drop of water you have
information about the phytoplankton
bacteria
different organisms that have impacts on
ocean and
human health zooplankton and even for
larger organisms that travel through
that water they
might leave skin or fecal or tissue
cells
something that's known as as edna so
really the key
for a lot of us is to access that
molecular information that's captured
within that particular droplet
and that gives us accessibility towards
you know
what kind of biodiversity is present how
do organisms respond to their
environment
are there things that are harmful or
toxic um and then
also a lot of things a lot of research
is also geared towards looking for
specific organisms that can be
indicators of
environmental change and most of that
requires that that droplet of water or
that sample of water
be assayed by molecular methods and
traditionally access to molecular
information has really meant returning
that sample to a short side
laboratory for processing
and so what i'm going to really talk
about today is how we can move
those molecular methods onto aquatic
robot
robotic samplers and that means kind of
three big things
if you're operating in the field you
have to know how to collect a sample and
that sample has to be representative
of what you're trying to process for the
method that we've utilized
is particle concentration mainly by
filtration
and then you have to determine steps
that are required for hands-off fluidic
manipulations and those include things
that
and in different methods like eliza for
say the detection of toxin
or qpcr for maybe the detections of
genes and transcripts
and it's not just the steps that are
required for that but it's also handling
it in ways that aren't normal
for example if we're going to deploy
this there's no refrigerators and so
things like reagent stability is really
important
you can't always grab a clean epitube
and so you're reusing a lot of these
fluidic paths and so it also means
being able to clean up properly between
samples
and you know in a lot of oceanographic
research i'm going to sort of talk a
little bit about some of the issues
you're not necessarily dealing with just
plastics you might have to utilize
different types of metals which may or
may not be compatible with some of the
reagents
that you have and so the lab provides a
really benign environment
to do research it doesn't change very
much in temperature and you have a lot
of access to things
but as soon as you go into the field all
of these new things kind of crop
up and so i'm going to talk a little bit
about some of the challenges of working
in the ocean and for those that work
in the field some of these challenges
we'll we'll
they'll be very familiar with one of
those is power how do you
operate your instruments and when you're
in the lab you have a really great
source
of 120 volts that's almost continuous
and you can have as many instruments as
you wanted
as you want plugged into that outlet
but as soon as you go out into the field
it means operating on batteries so most
of the time we're operating on a limited
amount of volts
14 volts is what we're really pulling
from we also deal with a lot of
different element
elements we're out in the uv if you're
in the upper water column
we also have to deal with saline water
and that's really a big impact on what
kinds of
metals you utilize to build your
instrument out of because you have to
face then metal corrosion
ph and temperature may also fluctuate
one of the biggest ones in that we deal
with in the ocean environment is
pressure and
if you look at the top of the screen
there's a video of a
styrofoam cup shrinking as it's being
carried to deeper and deeper depths and
what's happening is the air is being
squeezed out of that
particular cup and if you look at our
instrument here's an example of a diver
again
hanging out near our esp and
if you think about what pressure is
doing on that can and our instrument
inside it's like at about 33 feet below
the ocean surface we already have
one elephant standing on that on the lid
of that can
if we drop down to 100 meters we've got
5.5 elephants standing on that can so
pressure is a really big thing that we
have to overcome
as we try and access deeper depths in
the ocean
and lastly biology and biofouling is is
a big deal so there's the can on the
right that just went in it's really
clean and pristine
and one month later you can see how many
things have decided to
take up residence on our particular can
so biofiling is a is a big deal because
it can change the weight of your
instrument
things like birds or seals can perch on
different buoys
and your instrument could even be
attacked by a shark
and so our solution to a lot of these
issues initially was the second
generation environmental sample
processor or esp
and this particular instrument it's an
electrochemical device
you'll see bags and those are our
reagents that are
that get get accessed by various valves
we operate in a currency called a puck
and this these particular pucks we can
load different kinds of filters
in them and they get loaded into this
carousel
and what i'm going to do is show you a
video as to how this
instrument performs under water and
you'll see this
surface expression is at the top um this
particular instrument is moored
it's hanging below that surface
expression and what's going to happen is
that video is going to cut away
and it's going to show you how that
particular instrument works
and so the first thing that's going to
happen is that we're going to load a
puck
into a collection position and we're
going to make a fluidic connection with
a clamp so that we can access seawater
seawater is going to be drawn in across
the filter
organisms are going to get concentrated
on that filter we'll then
add a kaotropic agent to lys those
particular cells open to make the dna
rna proteins all available
we can collect that lysate or homogenic
then load another
puck that contains an array of organisms
that we're interested in detecting
we can add that lysate we generated it
can bind to spots on that array we then
wash it away and add reagents to develop
that array
and then at the very end we're going to
take a photograph and that'll tell us
what kinds of organisms were present in
the water so this is a detection for
ribosomal rna
and in this case it's for
bacterioplankton and the best part of
this
is that all that data gets beamed back
to shore within about an hour and a half
of a sample being collected so some of
the lessons that we learned from
deploying these second generation
esps was that being at a moored location
wasn't actually always the best and a
moored vocation means a fixed location
and so in 2015 we used both fixed
and mobile assets in order to track a
harmful algal bloom that occurred in
in 2015 and what this plot shows
is data from our mobile asset this is
this autonomous underwater vehicle
that was able to provide information
about the water column so here's depth
from 10 meters down to 40 meters
as that vehicle moved offshore and what
it did is measure chlorophyll in the
water
and here you can see a ton of high
chlorophyll water that's this red band
that stretches from near shore to
offshore and what you also see
is the star where our instrument was
deployed
and it was connecting collecting
real-time data as to
toxins that were present in the water
but as you can see we're missing
the peak of the bloom in addition we
also learned a lot of lessons about our
chemistry
and one of those is that we were
utilizing custom reagents so you
couldn't buy those commercially
and they weren't necessarily in standard
use in many laboratories
in addition we had to use multiple
extraction reagents in order to get
measurements of toxin as well as the
presence
of the algal species
and that meant taking more samples just
to determine the presence of those two
analytes and in addition many of our
automation steps require just way too
many steps in order to
analyze a sample and one of those
examples is in this automating of qpcr
so we'd have to collect a sample
lace it with guanidinium and then run a
column purification that was multiple
wash steps
and then elude it in water before you
could even utilize that
um that dna in a qpcr reaction
and lastly we would have to then when
we're finished clean up and reuse
all those fluidic paths and we noticed
that sometimes we were really prone to
contamination
so that information really led us to two
solutions one is we really wanted to
keep it simple keep the chemistry simple
and to have a platform that allows us to
go mobile
and so this is a a design overview of
our third generation esp
we're much smaller than um that second
generation esp so we went from about the
size
of a large garbage can a can a large
garbage can
down to about the size of an instrument
of say two basketballs okay
we also want to preserve the ability to
sample and preserve those samples to
bring it home for laboratory analysis
but we also want to make sure that we
can create a homogenic
homogenate and then analyze that and
provide data still
in in real time and a lot of the
analytical modules that we're targeting
for downstream
again is for toxin and also nucleic acid
detection and so right now we're working
with
um a surface plasmon residence where
we're utilizing that
to detect toxins you um via a
competitive elisa method
and then eventually we're trying to work
out how to design that analytical module
for both pcr
and for sequencing and so all of our
upstream
processing has to support those
particular methods
and what we came up with is this idea of
a cartridge a cartridge is basically
going to handle all the sampling
and all the processing that needs to
happen
upstream of handling that off to an
analytical module and this is just sort
of the comparison between the two
instruments so remember the esp we have
all these common reagents um we have
that carousel of pucks
and it's this large instrument that then
supports running
all of those samples that can be housed
in it so now we're moving
on to this cartridge it fits into your
hand and it's everything to collect and
process
one sample so a very very different way
to lay things out
this cartridge then gets plugged into
our instrument
this is the third generation instrument
portrayed here
these cartridges get loaded into the
carousel
this is where they make a fluidic
connection to the seawater and so you
have ability to concentrate
particles on a filter there's also this
reagent side to the cartridge that
interacts with different actuators that
we have here and we're able to move
fluid in and around
and off cartridge and the presence of
this minion down here well that's where
this analytical
module is going to sit when we deploy
in in the water column and this is an
example of a full ring of cartridges
loaded
into our carousel we're getting ready to
deploy this particular
instrument
a cartridge that selected that runs this
license process
is one that we're actually trying to
analyze the sample in real time
and so the steps that are involved in
that mean that we need to
collect and concentrate particulates in
the water in the water column
we're going to evacuate that sample
water we're going to add a lysis buffer
and heat we have to be able to recover
that extract
and then we're going to push that
extract off cartridge for analysis and
that could involve
dilution with different types of
reagents
and so that real-time analysis is really
dependent on sample homogenization
this is an example of our lysine go
cartridge
it requires heat so that there's some
sort of additional
features to this cartridge and what
we're really going for
is a single lytic agent for all target
molecules and this means something
that's compatible with both toxins and
also for
nucleic acids we also want to know that
the reagent or lytic reagent is stable
at room temperature for a really long
time okay
we're not going to operate in a
refrigerator
we also want to minimize the number of
steps that we have to do before we
deliver
to the analytical module so we don't
want to process very much
and so what we really did is start
looking into the field and looking at
different companies that were developing
different um
lysis methods and we ran into this
company microgem that produced rna gem
and preptim
and they offered a solution where
there's a cell lysis
and no purification and so this sounded
really good to us
so we started doing is trying to look to
see whether or not rna gem will meet our
needs and
these next set of experiments we did in
a laboratory and really controlled
setting and in
in eppendorf tubes and in sort of normal
laboratory tools and we will ask three
different questions
one whether or not it lyses our targets
and that means it has to meet or beat
our current methods of extraction that
we utilized on our second generation esp
the buffer system also needed to be
compatible with our target molecules
for us again that means nucleic acids
and some low molecular weight toxins
and most importantly it had to be stable
at room temperature over a long period
of time and so we were trying to shoot
for at least a month
because of how we were operating with
our mobile asset and this means two
different things
one is the reagent stable at its working
concentration
and then ideally the extract that it
produces would also be stable so that
whenever we got back
after a deployment we could actually
still utilize that extract that was
produced
this first slide shows a comparison of
the lysis methods and we were looking at
nucleic acids and so we were experi we
were comparing different methods of
extraction
one is that we compared rna gem to a
kaiogen all-prep method that utilizes
beat beating
and then secondly we compared it against
what we utilized for our
second generation esp which is basically
a modified dna easy
column extraction we used 12 different
seawater samples that were
acquired through different seasons and
at different depths to get a really wide
range of different organisms that we
might target
and so on the x-axis is these different
genes that we targeted in the
bacterioplankton
those range from bacteria also archaea
and then a diatom or a
phytoplankton and what this graph really
shows
is the log difference between rna gen
minus that
from the other extraction method and
anything above zero basically means that
rna gem
won out and so in comparison to our
second generation method
um it's kind of a no-brainer um the rna
gem
definitely outperformed as far as it
versus a method that utilizes bead
beading there were some groups where it
was
um better with the rna gem and other
groups where it was worth
worse one of those um synicococcus cbbl
is is known to be
um a hard to life sample so that one
wasn't surprising that um
it actually worked a little bit better
with the bead beading method
then we looked at the stability of the
enzyme over time and we stored
this enzyme in working concentration so
it was in a 1x aliquot and we stored it
in room temperature
in the dark and then we looked at a
shallow water sample and a deep water
sample and we assayed for those kind of
same with those same groups so we looked
at
the presence of total bacterial 16s
an archaeal species and also the diatom
and we looked at this over a wide range
of time so we went anywhere from t
0 all the way up to 334 days and what we
found was is that
enzyme was stable for really long
periods of time
and there really was no significant
differences between any of the time
points that we collected
and so this was a really great find for
us because it meant that
we weren't just limited to just one
month or a few week deployments
we could actually be out with this
particular lysis buffer for
really extended periods of time
we also then looked at the stability of
the extracted nucleic acids
over time and really what this does is
provide an option to utilize that
extracted sample post recovery
and so if we know that the extract
hasn't changed that it's representative
of whenever we made that molecular
measurement
this is a really good asset for us
because we can confirm or
perform additional assays
and so what we did is we reanalyzed an
aliquot of the t0
extract that was held and held that at
room temperature over time and then
analyzed that
with qpcr and we utilized the same
targets
so we have the surface and the deep
water sample this is the log gene of
abundance and this is
over time so black is t0 24 hours is in
red 13 days is in green and you'll see
that we didn't have
any significant differences after 13
days
um we did and then we analyzed it 49
days we had one
replicate from day 49 in the surface
sample that was significantly different
but regardless this is really promising
results for us so
if we can get our cartridges working
then at least we know
practically the sample that gets
extracted is representative
utilizing this particular buffer system
we then started looking at what happens
to lysis onboard 3g we're utilizing this
in a different way it's a different
materials
we're handling it very differently and
so what we're trying to do now is
compare
our 3g esp process to the bench lysis
and so there's two different experiments
that happen every time we
utilize one of these instruments in the
field we do a pre-deployment positive
and in this case the rna gem has been
loaded in the cartridge and then added
to the instrument it usually takes us
about 40 48 hours
in order to set up this particular
experiment
we then run our pre-deployment positive
we do three runs on the bench with the
same water as we use
on the esp and this is before it's
deployed
so that tells us when we get it back and
we and we analyze the extract
it tells us how long our extract is
stable and what we found is
a little bit more variation within the
esp collected sample
but those samples were representative of
what we collected
um on the bench we then can also
do another post-deployment positive and
that tells us information on how long
the rna gem
was stable in our cartridges and in this
case it was 14 days
was the duration of this particular
deployment and we found that
the the instrument that went into the
field
with those cartridges and that was
stored for 14 days or just as good as
um rna gem out of the fridge and so
those were our
our bench controls and so this really
shows that at least
operationally what we're doing um
is is working and the samples that we're
collecting are representative
of of what's going um of
our representative of how we're
collecting samples
in in the water column
so everything that i've discussed so far
has shown that rna gem
is compatible with looking at the
various nucleic acid targets we're
interested in
but i also want to talk about some toxin
analysis because that's
also really key we really want to try
and do this real-time toxin detection
and initially we started looking to
target domoic acid and it's a neurotoxin
from marine algae it's a common issue in
in monterey bay we have
harmful algal blooms that generally
occur each year the method that we're
going to utilize to detect is a
competitive elisa using an sbr and
here's the 3g instrument with this
analytical module the embedded spr
within it and traditionally the
extraction method that we've utilized um
on our second generation esp was
um 50 aqueous methanol with 0.1 percent
tween
20. and i want to we're going to compare
that with rna gem to see if it's
compatible because
if it is then we're able to basically
get
to collect one sample and be able to get
toxin and gene measurements out of a
single extract
in order to see if this is going to work
we have to actually compare two
different things
we have to know if that buffer is
compatible with running spr
and the second thing is to know that if
we run the extraction
if we're able to extract toxin
so the first slide is showing that rna
gem is compatible with competitive elisa
so again that target was domoic acid we
extract
and compare the two different generated
standard curves
with both aqueous methanol and rna gem
and the curves are located on your right
the top is the one for the methanol
curve and what's really important here
is the dynamic range of this particular
curve
and so if you look at the dynamic range
of methanol and compare that in the
lower
red plot of that for the rna gem you see
that that dynamic range is a little bit
different but it's not
grossly different and so this was really
promising for us
in order to proceed into actually
testing to see if rna gem is effective
for
extracting the toxin um and this was
work again done by uh
greg doucet and this is some of his
unpublished data so
in this graph it's showing you the yield
of domoic acid from a culture
and this is utilizing this methanol
tween method that we utilize on the
second generation esp it's incubated at
60 degrees
he also did a control where he increased
the temperature to 75
and then we compared that to extraction
using rna gem
and what you'll see is that the yields
might be a little bit different
but they're still in a very comparable
manner and
it's very very doable and so this was
acceptable results and so now we're able
to basically be
we can use the same extract to look for
the presence of a toxin
as well as to look for the the presence
of the organism in addition to detecting
these marine algae we also found that
rna gem was effective
at looking for other low molecular
weight
algal toxins including ones found in
freshwater environments
and to that end many of you will be
familiar with a harmful algal bloom that
happened in 2014
that shut down close the toledo water
supply
and so about a half a million people
were unable to drink their water
they couldn't cook or bathe for almost
three days because it was contaminated
by a toxin produced by a harmful algal
species in in lake erie
and one of the reasons for that is
toledo's water supply is actually
located
right here and this particular area of
lake erie is very very prone to harmful
algal blooms and a lot of these are
fueled by agricultural runoff so here is
the water intake
um it's the water crib of where toledo
gets its water
and you'll see around this particular
crib you see floating on the surface
are these marine algae these toxins
these toxic this toxic marine algae
that's present
in 2019 we traveled to lake erie and
brought our instrument
in order to try and map out where these
toxins were present
so here's a picture of our of our
instrument getting ready to go in the
vehicle
and here's the vehicle flying in lake
erie
um and that you can see the the bright
green is the
is where these uh cyanobacteria are
located
showing you sort of the density and the
extent of it and if you look in the map
this is overlaid with a satellite image
that shows the extent of the bloom in
lake erie
and the more red the color the higher
the concentration of that particular
algae is
and so the stations that are listed on
this are stations that know a glorial
they visit and they monitor over time
and the red track that you see is where
we flew one
one of our vehicles to sort of look at
the extent of the balloon
and we were able to collect samples
along the way and those samples are
are being analyzed right now by um our
group and also
the group at gloro um to try and gain a
picture of of what the extent of that
particular cyanobacterial bloom was in
in 2019
so so far i've mainly spoken about
underwater applications of our
instrument but there are many other
aquatic environments that one might want
to sample
where launching in long-range auv isn't
practical for example traveling to
rivers or streams
so our solution was to repackage our
instrument into a more portable device
something that someone could carry into
the field
and that it could also be used as a
means to access
water quality
and it's known that many water quality
markers are are harder to lice
it generally means you're trying to open
ground positive organisms and so
harsher methods are are required in the
epa they use a mechanical bead beading
method
but that method isn't practical on our
cartridges so what we wanted to do
is is explore the use of two different
products
one rna gem and a second one prep gem to
see if enzymatic lysis can actually open
up these
gram positives and we want to do this on
our system on our portable system
in order to show that we can we can do
this
so what we're doing is we're targeting
these gram-positive enterococcus that
were added to spike seawater samples
um the we did um cultures to
to show the total number of enterococci
cells that were filtered in our samples
and then we also ran extraction tests
and so
the epa method is on is in the green
bars at the far right
and this is the enterococci the cell
equivalents that were filtered
in that sample so this is what was
recovered utilizing the epa
beating method that's in the green bars
these orange bars here show results
utilizing the rna gem
method and so you can see that
significant numbers
of the ener alkoxide in that sample were
not effectively lysed
by rna gem however utilizing the buffer
sister
system and the and the enzyme of prep
gem
we find that we actually beat the
lysis of the of the epa method and this
is all within the context of our
cartridge so now we're really poised
as to being able to take this portable
device out into the field
and then start looking for um uh
basically
fecal indicators and and and
assess conditions of of potential human
health impacts
most of the data that i've presented so
far has shown that we can collect
representative samples and process them
in a way
that's compatible with results to what
we've obtained in a laboratory setting
on this last part i want to showcase
what we envision is the strength of this
technology this idea of
a mobile genetic robot and i want to
start with a real example of ocean
sampling that we performed
a couple years ago in collaboration with
the university of hawaii
and the schmidt ocean institute and we
traveled off of hawaii about 100 miles
into the central pacific ocean
and we launched one of our vehicles to
study a really special layer known as
the deep chlorophyll max
and these deep chlorophyll are higher
in biomass than in the other parts of
the water column
and they're unique because they're in a
special place where they get
where these organisms get nutrients from
below and they're also in the layer that
where they can still have sunlight to
photosynthesize
so you get these areas of higher
biomass about
100 or so meters below the surface of
the ocean
so the goal of this particular
experiment
was to fly one of our vehicles inside
this deep chlorophyll max to
to acquire it and then to drift in it
over time
we then used the second vehicle oppa to
basically provide the environmental
context so it would fly
around the vehicle and provide water
column information above and below
as aku that the vehicle that was in the
layer
state this was really important because
if you leave the layer it's hard to get
back in the same location you were so we
were utilizing
two robots one to do the sampling the
other to provide the contextual data
we also wanted to stay under water as
long as possible so we also used a third
robot
a wave glider in order to maintain
the position of those particular
vehicles you can see we're also
way away on the ship keeping um and we
were able to keep
satellite communications so we can track
that we can track the instruments we can
also perform other experiments and then
come back whenever we decided we wanted
to
so the goal of this experiment was to
acquire that deep chlorophyll max
to remain in that feature and to archive
samples and that's what
aku's job was this is the sampling
long-range auv
we also again used opa to profile
around that long-range auv up and down
to provide the contextual information
so this video that i'm going to show you
is a
four day three night drift of the
sampling
av while the profiling av is going up
and down in the water column and
providing
the context so in this feature there's
going to be a black line that shows you
the trajectory of the
sampling auv and the colors are going to
be
the the contextual data that was
reported by the profiling auv
the left panel is in temperature and the
um the left panel is in temperature and
the right panel is in chlorophyll and
the more green this area is the higher
the chlorophyll
so what you're going to see is this
black line this is the sampling
av you can see that it's sticking in
this particular
green chlorophyll it's staying at that
temperature and it's acquiring samples
over time and it's able to stay and
remain in that layer
what you might also notice is how much
that layer moves around it's moving at
least by 10 to 20
meters per day night cycle and so we
were able to maintain
and stay in that particular feature and
drift with it
over time so the hawaii example shows
the ability of the long-range av to find
and remain in a particular layer
and we envision that the real-time
molecular data will also inform when and
where to sample
for example if you wanted to really wait
till you saw a big bloom
you might have deployed before where you
don't have a very high chlorophyll
signal and organisms say
in this quadrant aren't present and so
you don't want to waste samples
so you're going to fly the av around and
collect samples every once in a while
until all of a sudden you reach a high
bloom condition where you see high
chlorophyll
and those organisms that you're really
interested in studying
are present and then they're going to
kick off and collect extra samples
in those particular areas and so this is
how we envision having
an intelligent sample scheme
and our ability to react to a situation
really depends on how quickly we can get
that molecular
real-time data and figuring out what
reagents and methods
has really that support that goal has
really been an
important component to the development
of our esp
i want to acknowledge members of the esp
team and that's in the upper picture
as well as members of the esp long range
auv team and that's the lower picture
some of the work that i also presented
was work that we did with the university
of hawaii including um
with edelong and dave carl and then our
collaborators from noaa greg ducette
reagan era
steve ruberg paul daniel and kelly
goodwin
and the majority of this work was really
is was funded by the david and lucille
packer foundation the betty and
gordon moore foundation and a few nsf
grants
to chris schulman thank you very much
for listening and i'll take your
questions now
there you go i can't see anything
and thank you christina for that
informative presentation and we'll start
the
live q a portion of the webinar now so
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's take a look at our questions
already coming in
casino our first question is
what is the salt concentration of the
concentrated
sample and do you have downstream issues
with qpcrs if so
do you make any additions to your pcr
mixes to improve the simplification
well thanks susie for that question um
whenever we try and sample we're
concentrating seawater which has a
salinity of about 35
parts per thousand but
the particles are getting concentrated
not the salt on the filter and so one
of the methods that we utilize to get
rid of the
the sample the sample itself is we
evacuate
all the sea water out and so when we add
the buffer we have less than
um between somewhere between 100 to 50
microliters of residual seawater left so
it's
it's not making a big impact on our
sample sometimes we do have
inhibition that comes in with the sample
and we've overcome that by just doing a
simple dilution so usually
a one to five uh or a one to ten
dilution
is enough for us to get past the
inhibition and that usually has to do
more with the organisms themselves than
the seawater
and how can we ensure that the sampling
process itself
does not disrupt the marine environment
yes that's a great question um ambari we
sit too
at the in a marine sanctuary so we are
very um we are much more restricted with
what we can
do in the bay and we're a lot more um
careful here
everything that we deploy we have to
recover so all the equipment we have to
bring back includes recovering anchors
that are that are we utilize
to hold our instruments in place we also
don't um release any chemicals so
anything that we
um what we do release is the filtered
seawater
but we don't release any other chemicals
whenever we
are sampling we have waste containers
inside of our instruments that hold all
of that
material so it's really the structure
that might
impact organisms within the marine
environment but we
again after we're done sampling we
remove that from the environment
thank you christian i want to thank our
audience these are great questions
coming in we have quite a bit we'll try
to get it to as many as we can
this next one is a couple of part um
two-part questions
what are the advantages of conducting
research
in laboratories at sea that's the first
part
and what kind of underwater research can
produce results more effectively
than research that can be done on land
in particular what kind of research can
be done
under water that are not directly
related to marine life
okay those are really great questions um
uh first of all
it has to do with when you really want
that information for
for us if you're thinking about
monitoring or even like
a management situation or you want to
find an environment
where you can target organisms that
you're really interested in
it's nice to be able to have that
information before you start
sampling rather than after you you go to
all this really big effort
um in terms of uh things that are more
amendable
obviously the less steps um and things
that are easy to automate
are are much simpler things that take a
lot of
processing or a lot of steps or require
a lot of
informatics to interpret results are a
little bit
harder so we found that things that are
much
faster almost like a point of care where
they give you
an answer that you can then react to
have been
the best there are
definitely methods that are not amenable
to
to working underwater or at sea and in
those cases things like where we can
archive samples or
in the case where um the enzyme
is able to whatever we lice or the
homogeneity that we get back if that's
stable and we're able to analyze that
further when it gets back to shore
those are all things that are are really
important to supporting this kind of
research
and that's been kind of a key um
to us developing this instrumentation is
to know what we bring back
into the lab with the instrument or what
we do at sea actually matches
what normal laboratory methods
have provided over the years
and then the last question was the
organisms that aren't sorry that aren't
directly related to um marine life
um this type of technology um you can
also utilize to monitor for human health
uh targets so there's um obviously
large people a large groups that
manage human pathogens
that they assess water quality and they
close or
shut down beaches and this type of
research or
instrument can actually be utilized to
give more information
in a faster more real time and so it
would just be
working towards qualifying this
particular type of instrument for that
kind of
management resource and so it's really
about
trying to provide information about the
environment
in in real time
thank you christina this next audience
member
has a question about contamination does
working in
oceans increase the chance of
contamination
um it definitely does in that one of the
pictures that we had showed earlier
there was a lot of of bio fouling so it
really depends on where you're at so
in ambari sometimes we operate during
phytoplankton blooms or in coastal areas
and those instruments
do get biofiled we try to
utilize like copper screens and things
like that that might minimize
different types of contamination we also
have ways that we can
internally clean our tubes to try and um
our sampling tubes in order to
keep down different types of biofouling
but that's definitely an issue in the
environment um
and we try and look at targets too that
may or may not come in on that
particular bio
that particular um uh like
sorry we try to target organisms that
aren't necessarily associated with
biofouling
but that's um yeah one way that we do
that
thank you and how long do robotic
samplers laugh
that's a great question so a lot of
times we
we are um at the mercy of how much power
we have and so
like the mobile device that particular
one
will last about three weeks out at sea
um the mooring that we showed you that
one
has operated on its own battery pack for
about
six months and then we've also operated
there's a cabled observatory that's um
that's present in the monterey bay and
we've been able to plug in that and we
were
plugged in and underwater at 800 meters
for about eight months
so a lot of times it really has to do
with your power
it also has to do with how many samples
you want to take during
that particular period so if you want to
try and take a sample a day and you have
in our carousel for the um for the
the mobile device there's 60 samples so
there you're really limited to say
60 days if you could if you could be out
that long and so it really depends
on how frequently you want to sample
where you want to be
how often your phenomena occurs so those
are all
questions that whenever we whenever we
lay out a deployment those are all
things that we have to answer
thank you christina and again i want to
thank our live audience for their
participation
great questions coming in any questions
not answered today will be answered via
emails from our presenter
our next question could you talk a
little bit about
how this remote sampling and analysis
has impacted your resource
allocations i'm wondering about savings
in terms of
transporting the water samples reduced
lab plastics or
others well you definitely um
get uh really good samples it impacts
because you don't have a human
that has to go out and collect those
samples and filter them and then bring
them back to the lab
the added benefit of those lysing
cartridges is that all of that lysis is
done
while the um well the vehicle is out and
so you're getting homogenous back that
can be directly analyzed so it's really
just then recovering that
off of the cartridge our cartridges
right now
are we reuse them and so we clean them
um and then reuse them again and so
there's less plastic waste
in that in in that realm and then we're
not using as many
tubes and things like that and that's
been really the
the biggest benefit of that particular
cartridge and and that method so it's
not just the real time but it's also
the improvement on processing whenever
you get back to the lab
thank you for that this next question
actually piques my interest too
has anyone thought of using this in the
testing of coded
deploying to non-urban areas for testing
um you you certainly could it is a water
sampler it can be utilized
and it can take on any type of water it
would really be
right now we don't have the downstream
pcr requirements instrument in order to
do that analytical
um provide that information in in real
time
but that's definitely something that the
instrument can do those are targets that
it can handle
um and if um
if that were something that somebody
wanted to try it would be
possible now christina is all your
molecular research limited to pcr
amplification studies or do they
progress to
amplicon sequencing of say the 16 sr dna
to understand community representation
so we definitely want to try and move
into sequencing we've already started
one of the other groups that we're
collaborating with at ambari
has started to utilize um the lysates
that we generate on those lysate
on those cartridges to see how they
represent how different um
groups represent they're mostly
targeting a larger
zooplankton so going after more edna
products and so that's definitely a vein
that we're going down
a lot of the initial analysis that we
did
was to utilize qpcr because it's much a
quicker turnaround
and it's easier for us to identify
issues
and since a lot of the some of the
sequencing technology relies on
a targeted pcr approach
if we can get the pcr to work and it
looks and it's good enough and it's
representative of what we normally see
in the lab
we feel like it's a a good transition
to get to sequencing
thank you very much now how often do you
analyze
the maroon water how often do i
excuse me how often do you analyze
the marine of water so
a lot of times what we're doing in the
lab is a lot of development
but we try and um we try and do a number
of deployments per year
in the monterey bay we have between two
and three big expeditions where we
target
particular events so we've done things
like studied
uh daily migration of zooplankton
and looked at that acoustically and then
targeted samples in
in high acoustic layers we have an
upcoming deployment where we're going to
look at canyon dynamics and so the
distribution of different types of
fish and and bacterioplankton and
harmful algal blooms around the bay
um we also generally do one to two
deployments
outside of our our area and so um the
example that i gave in lake erie we've
been there for the last couple years
sort of utilizing this instrument in a
different
environment so we're working in more
shallow waters fresh water
and and for a um a group that does more
moderate
monitoring thank you for that
now what are the ill effects of the
algae bloom
excuse me what are the ill effects of
the algae blooms
so it depends on the the type of toxins
so the
harmful algal blooms that occur in
monterey bay they're the cause of a
of a dyna a diatom called pseudoniccia
australis
and here the toxin that's produced is
called domoic acid
and that particular toxin is a
neurotoxin so it has a huge effect on
a lot of the seals and birds in this
area and that particular toxin it
bioaccumulates
so the diatoms produce it then the the
anchovies or sardines eat it that toxin
gets accumulated in their body so any
marine organisms that eat that go
through this um
they suffer this neurotoxin and it it's
causes them like an amnesic
and they they lose their sense and they
uh it affects their
brain and their hippocampus and it is
reversible if it caught early
um and that can also um cause issues to
human health as well and has caused the
closing of
numerous fisheries here in up and down
the coast of
um the us on the west coast for example
the um it was the uh
dungeness crab was closed in 2015
because of the domoic acid bloom
in lake erie the toxic cyanobacterial
bloom
occurs there and affects the toledo
water supply that same
cyanobacteria is also present in like
the st john's river
along in the coast of florida and those
particular cyanobacteria can get to
really high levels
and that's toxic to anyone that takes
their
pets to the beach or interacts with that
kind of water
thank you for that now could you
extrapolate how your technology has been
used or could be used for different
environmental applications
for example crop or pest management
so a lot of this is is trying to figure
out ways to provide information in real
time and really our
our instrument is really just a sampler
it's good at sampling water
and that what we really tried to target
was to
make that our instrument very um
modular so that anybody that wanted to
develop an assay or add their own buffer
as long as they could operate within
that structure of a cartridge then that
can work
we also try to make it modular in that
any kind of analytical module could be
plugged in so we would provide a
power and a fluidic and a calm link to
it
and so we would be able to adapt
different types of technologies so we're
not stuck on just
one so as something new comes open or
there's a new application
then we can figure out how to wrap our
heads around
what steps have to be done in order to
meet those requirements and and that's
really how we've
we've um progressed even into working
like into the fresh water environment
because you can imagine you know those
owl cells or the types of samples that
they want to take being more near
surface
operate really differently in shallow
water than how you would operate
here in the ocean and it you know the
sample matrix is different the types of
organisms
are different that and each of those
questions mean
mean changing either the chemistry or
sometimes
even the fluidic motions on the
cartridges in order to
make sure that we accurately represent
information within that sample
thank you christina we have time for a
couple more questions do you
use normal pcr or the qt pcr
so we've been using um quantitative pcr
because we really wanted to get
more than just presence absence so we've
done abundance so in our
in that second generation instrument we
worked with um
the lawrence livermore national
laboratory they had a um
a qpcr module that they had built for um
we had developed for anthrax detection
and so we had utilized that
inside of our instrument and we built
the pcr
reactions on it on a um and then
would push those into that module and so
that was our mechanism
of of testing when we move into the 3g
we're really trying to look at still
trying to do something
that will provide quantitative
information and whether that's via like
a digital pcr
or another type of quantitative pcr
where you're dealing with larger slugs
of fluid
both of those are really still on the
table and it really depends on
what works best with our system
thank you christina this last question
can you tell us about your first
experience in this field
how you felt working for the first time
and if there are any
common problems that you face in your
your work
so i'm a microbiologist and so this is a
really
fun project and it's really exciting
being able to watch
and see work using robotics in the field
you really you really get to be out
there
a much longer time frame you also get to
watch
like uh in that video that we showed at
the very end showing us floating inside
of a bloom
you really get to watch things change
and and alter so
it's this amazing experience of watching
things transform
in front of your eyes and it's really
that sense of of discovery
of learning something about the ocean
just as it's happening
in real time at that moment
absolutely christina thank you for your
presentation today
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience before we go
today
i just want to thank um lab roots and
microgem for this opportunity of sharing
some of the work that we do at nbari it
was a really
a great experience for all of us
and thank you christina for your time
and clearly important research
i'd also like to thank the labyrinth and
our sponsor microgem for underwriting
today's educational
webcast please go and visit
microgembio.com
to learn more about rapid single tube
extraction workflows
you can visit them at their site before
we go i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
libraries will alert you via email when
this webinar is available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time be safe and
take care
bye